[Music]
Joining me now, one of the speakers at
last night's free speech event in
Garland, Texas, Robert Spencer, who is
the director of jihadwatch.org. And as
we watch the that tape, you are right
next to Pam Geller on that day as you
were there when you heard that there had
been a shooting outside. This is a
strange question, but under the
circumstances, a valid one. Was it
unexpected or was it expected?
It was sort of neither one or both. We
were aware that this was something that
a lot of Muslims would be uh wanting to
kill over and we wanted to protect the
people who were inside. So we spent
$10,000 on the Garland police and the
Garland police did excellent job.
Oh my gosh.
On private security. We had SWAT team
there. We did made extensive efforts to
make sure that everybody would be safe
in the event that something like this
would happen. And it worked because the
jihadis were not able to get in. They
wanted to replicate the Charlie Hebdo
Jihad massacre. They were not able to
get to do it.
Were you scared?
No. At at that point it was something
that uh I was not really surprised
about.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean it's one thing to know it could
happen in theory and it's another to be
on the inside of the building
understanding two jihadis are outside
trying to kill you.
I'll tell you something. The main thing
that I was thinking was that uh I had
seen some care emails where they were
saying we have to
care council on American Islamic
exactly the Hamas linked to Muslim
Brotherhood front group and they had
said we have to make very careful we
have to be very sure to educate the
community so that they don't do they
don't react to this except in a mature
manner and I was just thinking oh
they're being immature again. I mean,
you're dismissive of it now, but two men
who two attackers are dead. A security
guard, a police officer shot in the
ankle and almost as soon as this
happened, people turned on you.
Yes.
And said it it's you invited it. I want
to make clear to the audience, I am not
saying that. But do you find it
incredible how people have turned it on
you?
You know, that was something I expected
even more. Uh what? Yeah. You know,
because this happens every time. We saw
it with the Charlie Hebdo massacre that
everybody was saying J Sweet Charlie
right after it, but now Penn wanted to
give an award to the Charlie Hebdo
editor and 145 writers have pulled out
and protested because it's Islamophobic
and it's I I expected nothing less here.
It's it's the reward of violent
intimidation. People are saying in the
face of violent intimidation, we have to
surrender and censor ourselves and
subjugate ourselves to it. Even Charlie
Hebdo has come out, some some of the
folks from Charlie Hebdo have said, "Oh,
we're nothing like them because we
criticize all religions. You're sort of
a hate group in their opinion directed
at one religion." So they say, you know,
not suggesting you're fair game, but
it's incredible how virtually everyone
has turned against your message. No
matter what you think of the message,
what no matter what you think of the
message, are we not on very dangerous
ground here where two assassins try to
kill innocent people exercising their
first amendment rights? And the question
the society is now asking is well what
were they saying?
That's exactly the problem that we're on
very dangerous ground because what we're
saying is if you kill enough people then
we will give you what you want and we
will turn on the people who won't give
you what you want and we will make them
the problem
and we're reward. Listen, nobody is is
there's no instantaneous or necessary
reaction to anything. If you insult me,
I don't have to kill you. I could walk
away and laugh. Look what they did when
they submerged when that so-called
artist submer submerged a figure of
Christ in urine. There was there was no
murder.
Yes.
And if there had been a murder, nobody
would have turned around and said,
"Well, you know, he really offended
those Christians."
Yeah. My reactions are in my control and
they're my responsibility. The Book of
Mormon very insulting to Mormons is a
Broadway show's playing right right up
strapping on a suicide vest.
Right. That's what Andy McCarthy says
today. He says the shooting last night
was not caused by the free speech event.
It was caused by Islamic supremist
ideology and its law that incites
Muslims to kill those they judge to have
disparaged Islam in his column at
National Review. Robert, thank you for
being here. Thank you.